what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the gray area of reactions yes the gray
area reactions where we get a little bit
gray and react to things that
have people speaking have people
thinking and most of all hopefully
red-pilling people
yeah because not everything in life is
black and white there you go
sometimes it's great
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell like the video guys
seriously it helps with the algorithm a
like is free so if you are watching this
what up guys i'm in the kitchen where i
belong sorry to take this break from the
video but i have an ad for you studies
have shown that our appearance affects
our mental health who would have thought
the anti-aging industry has tried to
capitalize on this for decades oh no but
their serums and their supplements they
fall short nasty and the reason for this
is that many of the products that are on
shelves in stores today they don't
target the source of the problem mostly
they just hide wrinkles using cheap
ingredients what the hey but i have an
alternative for you that's why i use
multi-collagen multi-collagen works to
restore the youthfulness of the skin
honestly guys between me and you it
helps combat wrinkles faster than
anything i have ever tried the reason
being is that it supercharges your
skin's collagen intake collagen is the
protein our skin needs to stay elastic
these products right here help deliver
collagen directly to your skin cells
that's why it's so effective imagine how
good you'll look this summer if you try
it today get up to 51 off by going to
healthwithpurley.com
or hear me out you can just visit the
link that's in the description
thanks guys back to the video
like the video come on and go subscribe
to sarah's channel as well subscribe to
my channel sarah garvey um like i said
you'll be seeing me all over pearl's
channel now yeah i'm here now i'm just
part of the furniture
okay so today we're reacting to it's
complicated great creator go subscribe
to him too um he does street interviews
with women and this is his most recent
one have you seen it yet nope i haven't
seen this one all right so this is the
rules of modern dating
why do women often crown themselves as a
queen
um
i would say we've just been mistreated
like a lot as a society i mean men in
general really mistreat women so
i feel like it kind of just puts us up
to call us ourselves a queen because
we're independent women who don't need
no men women are beautiful and they're
bad
and they're the creators of life
okay well well actually they say women
are the harborers of life because women
can't conceive without a man so
do women create life or do women carry
life because we can't have kids
emotional damage
all right first of all
this
mantra that men just are just out there
mistreating women
that was the first lady that was her
mantra yeah because men are like
mistreating women
like
where
and i'm not saying it doesn't happen but
women are talking as if it's the
majority of men that are mistreating
women well and here's the thing i'm like
have you never had any good men in your
life and that's the thing
so who are you picking like when you
keep saying men are like why are you
picking men that mistreat you yeah if
you don't like every girl has horror
stories of like of guys that like not
not not like abused but like like most
girls have picked a bad guy at some
point right
and and here's the thing you can either
take accountability and say okay there
are good men out there and maybe i
should look internal and get better or
you could say oh it's the world's fault
and it's all men it can't possibly be me
it's always our fault i don't know why
it's always our fault and it's just like
i just feel like everything in life is
your own damn fault i say this all the
time listen
they're already blaming men i'm a strong
i'm a strong independent woman and i
don't need no man i i don't know how old
she is
but
she won't be singing that tune very soon
no well and they're both pretty girls
that's the thing and but it's like what
like based on the girl on the left what
she's wearing what what messaging like
what type of guys are going to be
attracted to a girl with no shirt on
[Music]
and for what what are they going to do
yeah yeah yeah that's probably a better
word yeah what what are they going to be
what are they actually yeah what are
they attracted to well right but i'm
saying we need each other right carry
them in our womb and let them grow
inside our bodies like aliens but it
takes two people right
we're the ones who carry well we do all
the work and they get the fun
we carry the babies of the world like
you think that they would show us a
little more respect god damn it we are
the prized possession
is a woman doing the world a favor by
having kids
no
the world is overpopulated isn't she
just creating more traffic yes okay
uh
what
you know what's crazy
is we don't have enough kids to like
like the population's declining because
people aren't having as much care first
of all the problem first of all the
world is not overpopulated
there is so much land on this green
planet that has not been used and can
actually be used with still trying to
stay in harmony with the environment and
all that kind of stuff
so it wasn't overpopulated my dear
maybe she doesn't want to have kids but
it's sad because women are fed this
narrative
why are women nowadays so anti-child
they're so anti-children here here's
what i think happens okay i think most
women when they're like 18 they want
children and they want to be married
then i don't think most girls
understand
how out of their league they're batting
in general
really
yeah because i think most girls they
call themselves queens oh that's always
tense okay so the guys they deal with i
don't think they know they're out of
their league
does that make sense right so what i
think happens is they get their heart
broke or maybe have a bad experience
with one guy that they picked yeah and
then blame all men for it and then just
say oh instead of trying to get better
and trying to find a solution i'm just
gonna quit
or they didn't have a good strong father
figure in their life yeah but
to be so anti child because you can
you can put that down to abortion too
when she's talking about oh i don't want
to
the the worst over the world's
overpopulated and stuff it's just like i
don't know this new generation is a very
anti-child man
and it's feminism
yeah it's like it's fed to us
yeah
it's that's the media sad man
it's
your son are so cute
he looks he's handsome he looks just
like you just like just
uh women are special we literally
birthed the entire planet
but okay here's the thing dogs do that
dogs
did you see that
afterwards like she's like taking like
real pride
like nothing would be here without us so
if the thing that makes women special is
having kids why do so many women choose
to focus on their careers instead of
becoming mothers um well actually men
are lacking in the father department to
be honest with you i'm actually pregnant
and debating what to do about it simply
because of the shitty men that come up
to me every few seconds
why do women often consider themselves
the creators of life
she's pregnant right now
and she's debating what to do about it
she didn't think about these things
before that's like why are you sleeping
with a guy that wouldn't be a good
father
and then she's going to blame men and
she's going to blame men that men are
lacking and if you're going to do a good
freaking iud
wear a condom get an iud take the pill
and whatever it is that you need to do
just do it because you can't be pregnant
now on a on the road talking to it's
complicated talking about oh i'm
deciding what i'm gonna do with it you
didn't decide you didn't make a better
decision before it came to this it makes
me so sad we just saw the abortion
laughing laughs right exactly
oh gosh
because we foster that life
so don't women carry life
rather than create it
yeah
yeah i think that would be a good way to
say it yes well it does it the baby does
like a fetus starts off as two cells and
it multiplies in the woman's body
and it's
like like the nutrition comes from the
woman's body the energy comes from the
woman's body like all of that is from
the woman that's why
i'd say that they think they're the
creators
a man can repopulate an island full of
women can a woman repopulate an island
full of men yeah it would just take
longer so don't men create more life
gotcha bitchless
[Music]
do you know what it is what it's gonna
be right now right is there's gonna be a
need to be right
yeah so the answer that she's gonna come
up with is probably gonna be nonsensical
but her need to be right is to override
all the logic that she just heard let's
see
yeah they would create more
so then if anyone was the creator of
life wouldn't it be men
well i still don't think it's either of
them it's yeah i don't think i don't i
don't think it's either but i'm just
saying if anybody was going to create
more life wouldn't it be men yeah
yeah i guess that makes sense yeah
at a faster rate but you call but
one woman one man would create life at
the same rate do you think it's harder
to give birth or to raise a child
um harder to raise a child giving birth
is obviously extremely painful but
raising a child is you know if you don't
do a good job that child is going to be
screwed for life
raising a child anybody can push out a
baby like or get a c-section you got to
know how to take care of that child be
there for them i could see giving birth
being very hard you definitely have to
carry that baby for a night no one's
denying that yeah that's a lot you have
to go through okay but but taking taking
care of a child that's 18 years of
responsibility you have to put a roof
over that child's head close that child
feed that child that's that's a lot of
responsibility like once once the
woman's done birthing that child like
you have to be ready for what comes with
that child like there's a lot more than
just birthing our child so if the answer
is parenting then why don't single dads
get the same credit as single moms
i don't know
even on father's day they try to take it
away
listen well i'm so used to father's day
with women like coming out saying oh i'm
the father too
and you know my child's father's not
around it's like why are you so bitter
like on mother's day guys don't do that
yeah well it's crazy too because girls
will say that
even when the dad's in the picture yes
even when they're just single like
they're just literally single not a
single mother
i'm telling you the baby mother thing is
a
we need to touch on that we need to have
like a podcast on bitter baby mothers i
think you know who we need to bring back
i wish they did
uh
they're honestly just probably
overlooked there's not as many single
dads as single moms you hear about
single moms everywhere like i have a
single mom my boo has a single mom my ex
had a single mom i just know so many
single moms like
why isn't father's day given as much
attention as mother's day
fathers are absent that's probably why
why is it when a narrative
wow and she said that without flinching
well
honestly growing up that's what you
would hear about
but you didn't you never stop and ask
why are they absolutely yeah
why are they absent right is it as bad
as they say
right mm-hmm
is the mom keeping these kids from them
keeping the children are the women
incentivized to leave like there's so
many
micro problems that go into that issue
listen i could talk on this subject for
days so actually i have a question i've
asked i've asked a guy this before okay
and i said out of every 10
men that you know that aren't in their
kids lives
what percent of them is it their choice
and he told me ten percent
probably yeah that's what he said like
one out of every ten like genuinely just
listen i've known women to look in
father's faces and say
you're not seeing this child
and i don't care if the child grows up
hating you
and it's just like
how spiteful and bitter do you have to
be and that's what makes me so mad is
you were supposed to love the kid more
than yourself but like some of these
baby mamas they love selfish they love
themselves more than they could ever
love anyone even their own child and
that's what's so sad because like i
always say like but people always ask me
the cheating question like would you
stay if you got cheated on yeah and i
always say no until i have a kid like i
would not stay but if you have a kid
it's not about me my feelings come
second
and so it's like
it's like they
like with the mothers they literally
just put themselves first
is selfishness why is it when a father
abandons his child they call him a
deadbeat dad but when a woman aborts her
child they call it her choice
they don't uh
that's the rhetoric that i would like to
think but no if they get called they get
called they get called murderers
when in reality
you don't know
what brought them to that decision
i i don't know a woman who has been
happy about aborting a baby i think it's
mostly when
they know that they will be
a deadbeat
forty percent of abortions are second or
third abortions
forty percent abortions are second or
third which means people are
consistently 40 of the time making
bad mistakes right and you don't know
out of the rest of the 60 what percent
of them will get an abortion in the
future and you know what percent of them
are bought because of grape
oh it's it's less than two percent yeah
less than two percent yeah and because
that's the conversation you always come
up with oh but what if she was graped
that's less than two percent you're
talking about 70 no it's poor choices
every girl i know i know a couple girls
that have gotten abortions and like
honestly
it's because they're selfish people and
they're irresponsible like that is
literally what happened you know the
crazy thing is both the girls i know
their families would have helped them
they would have helped they absolutely
would have helped them like one girl was
her family was lawyers
they were rich
so
anyway this is like
when
when do we get to the point where we
just learn to have
protective sex
everyone everyone loves sex i get it i
get it guys protect yourselves that's it
you can do birth control on iuds you
don't need to be killing kids like
or you know if you can't afford a child
maybe you should try abstinence for a
little bit you can't afford a condom but
you can afford 18 years
of
of being
a mother no oh my gosh they don't have
money
they chew they choose to not have it
because they don't want to be the
deadbeat
should we support a woman who aborts her
child because she did what was best for
herself yes
why do we condemn men for abandoning
their children because they did what was
best for themselves because at that
point they are abandoning a developed
and birthed
child
versus abandoning or killing a fetus
it's not a human it's a fetus
why is it if a woman can't pay for her
do you know what's so crazy about that
argument
every life
starts somewhere
every life starts somewhere and 95
percent of biologists say that it starts
at conception it's not even argued in
the scientific community
there's a unique dna sequence that that
happens when the sperm and the egg be
and that that unique dna sequence has
the eye color personality traits it has
all it's a unique dna code that's
completely separate from the mothers and
fathers
and the crazy thing is i think if most
girls saw what an abortion looks like
against surgical it's so gross it's
disgusting it's they literally pull the
baby's limbs one by one smash the head
and crush your skull and suck everything
out
and it's just spoken about so like
casually oh it's just a fetus
but it's it's a child and the in the uk
legal up to six months six months oh
great like that is gross in in the us
they were
trying to put through
that that uh in congress that you could
do it for up to nine months
that's insane that's a whole these
people are literally insane
pay for her baby she gets government
assistance but if a man can't pay for
his baby he goes to jail
never heard of that one getting
government assistance does make sense
you have to make envy if you're gonna
decide to have a kid
instead he's being forced to pay child
support because he's absent again
sometimes i won't lie sometimes when a
lot of these women speak i'm just like
they say the exact same thing just over
and over again
believing
that it makes sense sometimes i think
girls just say things they just say
things i know sometimes to me sometimes
too i'll be talking i'm like what am i
even talking about
yeah that's true i'm speaking kind of
there's no need
it was 60 of single
mothers um
their fathers or their baby daddies are
not paying child support
so i mean there's a lot of laws that say
one thing uh and those lars aren't those
laws aren't really enforced unless the
offended party presses charges which a
lot of times that doesn't happen because
of how [ __ ] or sorry screwed up the
judicial system is
just talking to me talking
it's messed up
but uh they don't really show too much
love to men like like i said the court
system is for the women
uh the world is for the women as a man
you have to be tough and you have to
like [ __ ] it you know you gotta be like
okay let me ask you this if we live in
such a patriarchal society where did all
these laws come from that protect women
and punish men
i don't know that's that's a good
question honestly like because it's been
that way forever
is it possible that we don't live in a
patriarchy
definitely definitely that's definitely
uh opinionated thing everybody has their
own opinion i'm pretty sure the women
love how it is
but um like i was saying earlier like i
get it because you have to carry that
baby and all that but a woman could drop
her baby off at an orphanage you know
what i'm saying so
i am pro-choice yeah if a woman should
have the right to opt out of motherhood
and make that choice
should a man also have the right to opt
out of fatherhood and 18 years of child
support
not if the baby is coming into the world
unfortunately the baby will exist at
that point and need to already
and and this is how they get away from
accountability they say
it's not really a baby yeah do you know
what i mean it's like i don't have to
take responsibility for this life
because it's not really a child yet it's
just a fetus and that's how they try and
get away from their accountability of
their actions by actually um
dehumanizing a child so
literally in the uk there are babies
that have survived at 21 21 weeks and 24
24 it's legal to yeah how crazy is that
the world is crazy and and why and
what's the main reason that they're
aborting the majority of women
yeah it's like selfish and though in the
uk the number one reason when they're
surveyed because nhs surveys as to why
it's um my mental health basically
mental and physical health it's included
in physical but let's just be honest if
they're doing it two three times you
don't as i said you didn't think about
your mental health when you were having
unprotected sex yeah you think about the
baby's life do you think about anything
and why do you have to pay for it that
comes out of your tax dollars why why
like
i'm just lucky that i planned my son
yeah like yeah like he's not a mistake
you know like yeah he was supposed to be
here and i treat him as such do you know
what i mean because a lot of the time
when women
when they can't have an abortion
and they do decide to have the baby they
treat that child
like-ish that this child shouldn't have
been here like they really didn't want
to abort a child yeah
and i don't know do you guys have
something in the uk in the u.s you can
drop your baby off at a fire station no
questions asked asked
here no in the u.s sorry a fire station
yeah you can go to any fire station and
if you want you can drop your baby off
no questions asked
what yeah and then they like put it into
adoption or whatever
so they don't try to find the mother or
anything no
what kind of crazy law is that
i don't know you can just drop your baby
off well yeah it has to be specifically
a fire station yeah it has to be a fire
station
that's why this firemen are equipped to
have the babies like what the hell i
mean i don't know why i just know that
they take the baby and they put it into
the adoption system
i don't know if that happens in the uk
it could do i don't know if they have an
equivalent of that or something like
some if someone wants to give it up for
adoption they can like drop it off
somewhere there must be a place it must
be like them yeah that's just that's
just what the us is because there's fire
stations everywhere so i think it's just
if they need paramet like
they can get them i couldn't imagine
dropping my son off anyway
yeah i mean i mean i couldn't imagine
not taking care of my own yeah but i
also we don't believe in abortion either
right exactly
we don't
why should men be forced to be fathers
if women aren't forced to be mothers
they need to learn to keep it in their
pants otherwise honestly to keep your
legs closed yeah it's always
accountability on them never on us it's
always
let's hold
men accountable instead of let's take
accountability ourselves
is the man solely responsible for
getting a woman pregnant or does it take
two people it definitely takes two
people but for him to walk out of their
life that's his choice well for the
people who say that the mention
yeah yeah you literally are you have to
secure your own vagina you don't have to
[ __ ] the whole fifth you don't have to
[ __ ] the whole football team diane you
really don't
you don't and then it's his fool yeah
and then that the men should have
thought of that before they had sex
isn't that the same argument that
pro-lifers use against abortion
and not necessarily pro-lifers are doing
that because they don't think a life
should be taken
well i'm just saying if you're gonna say
that a man should keep in his pants how
is that different than saying a woman
should just keep her legs closed
it's not really different the difference
is the woman chose to be a woman and a
mother and have the baby and the man
chose to disappear and maybe pay child
support or not well why are we always
talking about the woman's choice she
knows she's wrong yeah as i'm saying
when they're wrong they just keep
talking yeah the woman's choice but we
never talk about the man's choice
women are just more degraded than men
are unfortunately i literally have men
coming up to me telling me they want to
spank me and do this and that and i'm
like dude this is the first time we're
talking i don't know you well why are we
what does that have to do with him
what does that have to do when all else
fails just be a victim yeah what does
that is nothing to do men told me that
he wanted to spank me and i don't know i
don't understand why girls are so
traumatized by cat calling you just move
on who cares like i literally don't care
i'm not i'm not traumatized because
someone cat called me like get over it
you have to ask women i did i think they
just like to complain because now now
men aren't catcalling and now men aren't
approaching women now women are like
they were in it for everyone i like to
be approached
don't
did you see the if you look good you can
approach me don't you see the viral
video of the woman at the mixer
this the the singles mixer oh we're none
of them
like guys are like we're done
but
yeah but you ladies go ahead though you
know you can go ahead and have your
little mixer yeah i like being
approached don't don't let these other
crazy women ruin it for all of us i
don't
always talking about the woman's choice
but never the man's choice because it
affects the woman's body and it does
affect the man's body okay but doesn't a
woman have the choice to opt out of
having her body affected
yeah but it doesn't affect a man's body
okay but it does affect a man's
future though yeah it does
okay so why
what reproductive rights do men have
um
they can use protection if they're
scared about having a kid they can use
abstinence if they don't want to have a
kid okay but can't women do all the same
things as well yeah so then why is
is the man solely responsible for
getting a woman pregnant or does it take
two people no it does take two people
but i think ultimately it is up to the
woman because it's her body that it
affects
why do so many women act like it's their
duty to have kids when it's actually
their choice
it's not always your choice well i'm not
saying always but isn't it usually their
choice it's not much of a choice she
said it's not always their choice oh so
whose choice is it
man
i mean unless a woman has you know
unconsensual
no she can't have a slip up she can get
raped it's all kind of stuff and some
women don't believe in aborting their
kids either so they just go with the
punches run with the flow keep the baby
don't women ultimately decide who gets
sex and who gets born
who gets sex yeah but now who gets born
what should they do because women always
have the option to choose whether they
want to keep the child or not right but
like i said some women don't believe in
aborting a baby so even if you're in a
bad situation so then have protected sex
if you don't believe in abortion
have protected sex that's the equation
right or am i missing something you're
not missing anything okay i was going
crazy you're not you're not going crazy
i thought i was going crazy you're not
keep it but that's still their choice
right and you make the right choice
tonight kill a life why do women often
clear that we agree yeah that is the
reason you make the right choice you're
not killer life but you can also make
the right choice to have protected sex i
feel like
i like the single moms that are just
like it was my own damn fault
just admit it
we would respect it a lot more
look
own it look at it i didn't want to wear
one
and this is the consequence but it's
never their fault often claim to be the
creators of life when the child is
wanted but when the pregnancy is
unplanned it suddenly becomes the man's
fault for not wearing a condom
i don't think it's the nose rings for me
i'm not gonna lie pose
it's the cattle rings question if a girl
so
no nose rings if you're dating a girl
okay whatever what about tattoos
it can't be excessive it can't be would
you prefer no tattoos or like small
tattoos
no tattoos i prefer no tattoos okay
whatever if you got like small like a
few small ones that's fine
i don't i don't prefer tattoos on guys i
but i know
a lot of girls do yeah but i don't
prefer it but i don't really care like
it's not a big deal to me but i feel
like i'm growing if a woman's got too
many tattoos it just screams oh yeah
yeah that's what i've heard yeah i'm
just like nah i'll stay away from that
i think that's like at least in my head
i don't think that's a popular opinion
um
i don't blame it on the men you know it
it does take two people right but but
why is it then that a lot of times you
know it'll be like the man got me
knocked up you know what i mean as
opposed to saying that it was two people
you know
that's a great question
yeah that you don't have an answer to
you so just take it don't talk for no
reason if i had to give a controversial
answer i think that a lot of it just
comes from
like a negative disposition towards men
that like most women tend to have
like for survival we have negative
dispositions towards men which is crazy
because you've needed men to survive
throughout all of history
we have negative
you literally need a man to survive
what did she even talk i told her i said
to her don't just start talking for the
sake of talking now
can you elaborate more on that what do
you mean towards survival um so you know
it's like it's really dangerous to be a
woman like every woman has a taser every
woman has pepper spray like you know
first dates are scary my friend needs my
location because the worst thing that
can happen is that i get sexually
assaulted and murdered but you know the
worst thing that could happen for a man
on a first date is that it just goes
wrong what's the worst thing that can
happen to a man on a first date um it
could be a setup
she could like be setting you up to get
robbed or something i don't know
okay i was just curious what like your
worst case scenario is if you go on a
date
that's my worst case scenario that's
your worst case i will say i think women
we do live in fear a little bit more
yeah you do
so
because
yeah
if i if i go on a date
i am a little afraid to get killed but
i'm also afraid to get killed by living
doing this this show
but i'm not afraid a guy is going to
kill me i think it's going to be a crazy
girl
that's the thing about being a guy
because you don't generally you you know
the you know
fear from other guys yeah that women
fear men like
guys fair guys
you don't play with this yeah you get
rejected not saying that none of that
can happen right but it's less common
and so i think that whenever there's a
negative situation and it involves a man
like the the disposition that a woman is
going to have is going to be negative
towards the man
so
at what point does that kind of become
like just
you know
abuse or man-hating
that's also a good question
i feel like if it's something that
you're being like intentionally hateful
or if you're intentionally trying to
hurt someone or if you're being
intentional your intentions don't matter
your actions matter
the road to hell is paid with good
intentions yeah
like it doesn't matter what your
intentions are it matters what are you
doing what are you doing yeah what are
the results people that obsess over
intentions always have the worst
intentions
i don't trust somebody who always says
um yeah my intentions were good because
i said i want to see the results yeah or
your actions yeah i want to see the
results i cheated but my intentions were
good
all right
i lied because my intention was to not
hurt you yeah all right androgynous then
that's whenever it like crosses the line
yeah if you're not trying to have a
debate or a conversation at least by
some sort of facts and you're just
bringing in your full opinion
um in a sense of like using insults
that's when it can be man-hating
and especially and vice versa from women
hating
if a man can impregnate multiple women a
day why would women consider themselves
the creators of life
i guess because in the end they're the
only ones who can bring about life
well a man can repopulate an island full
of women can a woman repopulate an
island full of men
no
so don't men create more life
they do unless the woman has a choice to
end it smash or pass
pause pass
i don't lack her attitude
true okay
what is a surrogate
somebody who has somebody else's child
i've read that scientists are developing
smasher pass
pause
any any smash
maybe you're on the left she's
if you had the option to become a mother
without ever having to physically carry
the child or go through the pain of
childbirth would you choose to do so yes
is that not adoption why
i would do it why
uh
first of all what if you pick the wrong
person to have a child with in the first
place
here it's automatically what could go
wrong
what if you picked the right guy the
choice is on you so you're just gonna
have to be more stringent with your
checks yeah
i'm i'm with it
that would be my fear
um childbirth can be traumatizing for a
lot of people it is it can be dangerous
especially if you don't have the right
health care so why would you want to put
yourself through that if you know
there's a safer option
so if artificial surrogates became
commonplace would that diminish women's
role
no because they would still need
well in other words if women and men
were reduced to egg and sperm donors
would that make women no longer special
no because you still need an egg in the
smell well right but i mean would that
make women
any more special than it would make a
man because they're both basically
donating dna
women women would be no longer the they
would no longer be the ones carrying a
child see the way society is set up
though it's still it would still be put
on the women because men are viewed
higher in society
i think a lot of women would still
choose to have the babies themselves to
feel closer so probably not
okay if women and men were reduced to
egg and sperm donors would that make
women no longer special
i guess if only you did that and nobody
had children then yeah i guess
why is society engineering women out of
the equation
i have no idea
i think there just might be more
either efficient or easier ways to do
stuff
maybe
maybe if i was a little bit drunk the
one on the left
a little
before modern medicine like the
mortality rate was pretty high
so like if you take kind of that factor
away it's safer for like both mother and
child let me ask
you
don't even ask no
she's kind of cute
if men can impregnate several women a
day but women can only get pregnant
once every nine months maximum
why does the birth control fall to be
the woman's responsibility that's a good
point but my question is
why are there more birth control options
for women than there are for men if
we're talking about hormonal there's the
pill there's the nuva ring there's an
iud there's the implant oh the iud has a
copper or hormonal option so it's both
um
we can also use barrier methods like a
condom a female comb condom a dental dam
but that's
right now only for oral but it can be
changed
um abstinence is technically a form of
birth control as well
it's pulling out a form
she's like i'm supposed to use it out as
a form it's a really low low low success
rate um
is it is it like nearly gonna happen
she's like i'll be putting out she's
like i'm not pregnant yeah it's been
working fine for me
what about for men
condoms
there's barrier methods for men and they
they have been trying to what percent of
girls ask you to wear a condom
um
they don't ask me i just do it okay but
like what percent of girls do you think
what
would make you i mean i'm not i'm not a
[ __ ] you know but i'm not a [ __ ] i'm
not like throwing my penis around out
here okay no no i just asked guys this
question and when they were they always
i'm just curious if you say the same
number i've asked other guys on the show
okay um i would say
how many what percentage of women would
ask me to use a card yeah
probably 50 50. you think it's that
that's the highest number
yeah you must not be screwing any hugs
no no because every guys i say they
always say like 10 to 30 percent
wow they say like yeah that's great yeah
there's vasectomies they have been
trying to develop hormonal options for
men but they're like
the side effects
are
apparently too much for men to handle
why are there more forms of birth
control for women than men
because it was always placed on the
women to control
it was okay for a man to sleep with
women but it was not okay for a woman to
sleep with a man so they're like
you gotta control it it's easier for men
to get a vasectomy because he can get it
reversed
cheaper
but a woman has to go through hoops and
and fire to be able to have birth
control or to get a hysterectomy
and even then like keep some fire for
buffalo like really
it's pretty easy to get so i
it's free in the uk yeah but in the u.s
it's really not hard either it's like
really bad for us and it causes us a lot
of problems like physically and mentally
why is there more birth control options
for women than there is for men
i think there just has been a lot of
research done through it to be
completely honest with you i think a lot
of it has to do with it just
that's how it is and so that's how it
stays
and like i think that a lot of men are
unwilling to do something for birth
control because
don't you think that if there was a
birth control pill for men men would be
all over that
i would hope so
i'm not taking any breath
i don't trust it i think most guys would
take it i don't trust it you think most
guys would take it
i think most guys would not trust it
okay
like i don't want to be the first guinea
pigs for the first melbourne but if it
was like the girls like where it's been
tested for like 50 years you think yeah
i would let someone else go yeah go
first go for it i'm not being no one's
gonna think when it comes to my birth
control that's like pretty much the end
of the video though yeah yeah yeah but
um what do you think it's complicated i
like the channel isn't it cool i like
the channel and i like the questions
that he asks and i like the fact that he
he asks questions
once he knows the answer that he's gonna
get he's got that he's got the question
ready for them for the follow-up so
yeah what it does show me like and i
said before a lot of women just talk man
like they just talk even though they're
they've been proven to be wrong they
will just continue to talk it doesn't
matter
at all you actually do a good job of
that on the show you always ask
questions i ask questions after the
question i let people speak you know i
let them try and
you know say their peace and then they
get angry when it gets clipped he's at
his ass girls do you do you think you
need to be right yes i did awesome yeah
so do you think you need to be right
like you need to be by yourself no
that's
oh my god
okay guys um
don't forget subscribe to the channel
and subscribe to mine um sarah gabi on
youtube the black opinion on instagram
and sarah garvey on tick tock and my
tick tock is going off he is it's
popping my ticket
popping
um like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time bye